όσο και να χερα να ποδεκτό για να προσπαθούσα ήταν μια πάρα πολύ μεγαλή πλήγι
και θα μπορούσε να παξει αρνητικό ρόλο στις επόμενες χρονιές παρόλα αυτά ο ερχομός πτου
λεονιά πολύ γρήγορα με αναστυνγκρώτησε μου εδώεβάλε τω μυαλό μου ν ναδηνίαφασεης άλλα πράγματα και
αυτό φάνηκε και το πόσον κατά να ποτελέσματα αυτή της τριατίας ανομικρός λεων είδα θέρθε
και σου πισε μερικά χρόνια ότι θέλει να σχοληθίμτο πλέογια είναι κάποιον άλλον άθλημα θα
είσ δίπλα τσίγονα θα είμει δίπλα του και σίγορα αυτό που θα κάνο δεν θα
τον πιέσω να κάνει κάτι θεθελείου είναι κάτι που ίδιηση ζητάμε με τη γυναίκα μου
οιδικάς είναι αρεσηλικές πιστεύω το πιο σωτόν και στο φόν για τα μορά είναι να
δοκιμάσουν πολλά θήματα τους βοηθαι να αναπτύξουν το σώμα τους αθήματα πως το κολολύμπι είναι
ριθμική γυμναστική είναι πάρα πολύ καλάσε ενάρες οι λιγιες και μετά ναμπαίνουν στα πιο ξιδιγεμένα
κάτι που κάνουν πολιώνεις πιχή που εραβάλουντα παιδιά του σας το ποόιφρα απου πολύ μικρινηδιγιά
πισευοδαίνειαι το πιόσωστόο αν μιλάς καθαρά βιολογικά για το σώμα και τη ανάπτυξη ενός μορού
καια τα παιδιά εδικά με χριηλιά το δέγα χρονών ακόμα και μέχρι τον δέδα κα
πρέπει ίνα ν επαιχνίδε τ νενα σχολισι με τα άλλα παιδιά δεν είναι αν είναι
καλύδερος από τος άλλουσι όχι γιατί το ποιο σημαντικών είναι να πολαμβάνουν αυτό που κάνουν
να κάνουν παρέσμε αλλα παιδι και αναπό μόνοι τους δουν ότι τους τραβά και θέλουν
να κολουθήσουν το τρόμο του ποταθτισμού τότε αι ενα ταακολθίζουν και στη συμι περιτο γιτουγιού
μας μισάμαστε δίπλα του ότιίνα αυτό που αποφασίζει ο ίδιας ότι θέλει να κάνει ίσως
να ανεχθός αθυλισμου παλιδιπλαδολ είμαστε κλείνοντας πο πλω θελά ροσ βακ ναστίλι ένα μήνυμα στους
αθλητές και δικά αυτούς που